ننتقل الى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس ومن
هناك اتينا هذه الصور مباشره
لوصول فرنسيين واجانب
الى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس تم اجلائهم
ضمن حمله اجلاء
لرعايه دول اجنبيه وعربيه من السودان بعد
ان تازمت الاوضاع مع استمرار الاشتباكات
والمعارك بين كل من قوات الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه اذا هذه الصور
توثق لحظات وصول اجانب وفرنسيين
للعاصمه الفرنسيه باريس بعد اجلائهم من
السودان عن ذلك نسال مراسلنا من باريس
محمد البقالي محمد بعنه في الاجواء هناك
مع وصول هذه الدفعه من الفرنسيين والاجانب
للعاصمه الفرنسيه
بالفعل هذه الدفعه على يعني اقول لطائره
على متنها 245 شخصا من الذين تم اجلائهم
وفقا لبيان وزاره الخارجيه
من بين هؤلاء مئه وخمسه وتسعين
رعايه ينتمون الى ايطاليا هولندا
هذه المجموعه
هي استمرار لعمليه
فرنسا منذ ثلاثه ايام والتي وفق اخر تحديث
ويتوقع ان يتغير هذا التحديث بعد هذه
الرحله كانت قد وصلت البارحه الى
5381 او من احدى واربعين جنسيه وبالتالي
يبدو كما اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان
عمليه الاجلاء مستمره وتتم الحديث عنها في
ظروف صعبه ولكن هناك ارتياح للنتائج التي
تحققها بالنظر الى انه لم يتم حدوث اي
خسائر بشريه باستثناء ما تم الاعلان عنه
البارحه من قبل الرئيس الفرنسي من اصابه
جندي ف من القوات الخاصه ولكن حياته ليست
في خطر وبالتالي يمكن ان نقول لحد الان في
انتظار التحديث الرقمي والنهائي من قبل
وزاره الخارجيه مئات قد تم اجلائهم من
الانسيين اقل من نصفهم من الفرنسيين
والبقيه هم من احدى واربعين امسيه من
مختلف دول العالم من الدول الاوروبيه
من اسيا من الولايات المتحده كانت
هي الفرنسيه اكدت البارحه ان عمليه
الاجلاء ستتواصل رغم اغلاق السفاره
الفرنسيه في الخرطوم وعوده السفتيره باريس
ونظره خارجيه اكلت على من جديد في بيان
اصدرته قبل قليل على ان فرنسا تعبئ كل
موارد الدوله من اجل انجاح هذه العمليه
ومن اجل مواصله عمليه الاجلاء وهذا الامر
ينظر اليه في على انه بالغ الاهميه
والشديد الحساسيه من جهه انقاذ المواطنين
الفرنسيين الموجودين في السودان وتمكينهم
من الخروج من الراغبين منهم وعددهم ليس
كثيرا على كل حال لانه لم يبقى منهم الا
القليل وعلى الاقل لم يبقى من الذين
يرغبون الخروج الا القليل ثم ايضا تقديم
هذه الخدمه خدمه الاجلاء لرعايه الدول
الاوروبيه الاخرى التي تطلب المساعده
وايضا لبقيه دول العالم وهذا الامر يندرج
بطبيعه الحال في الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه
التي تريد ان تقدم
الصوره واشعال فرنسا القادمه
للازمات مخطط الى فرنسا تستفيد
وجودها العسكري في جيب
1200 جندي يوجدون هناك ثم هناك
اليات عسكريه ومعرفه جغرا المكان وبما
يحدث فهذا هذا الوجود مكن فرنسا من قدره
على التحرك اكثر من الاخرين وبالتالي
فالعمليه تتم لحد اللحظه وفق ما هو مخطط
لها ووفقا وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه رغم
انها تتحدث على انها بالغه الخطوره
والتعقيد في الظروف الراهنه مع الاستفاده
من اجواء الهدنه النسبيه الحاليه على كل
حال التي
السودان
يمكن ايضا ان نقول انه هذا على مستوى
الاجلاء وزيره الخارجيه كما ربما نشاهد
كما يظهر في الصور انتقلت الى المطار من
اجل استقبال هذه الطائره وهو ما يؤكد على
هذا على اهميه هذه العمليه بالنسبه لسياسه
الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الموضوع السوداني ايضا يهم
فرنسا التي صدرت من وزاره الخارجيه على
امتداد الايام الماضيه واخر هذا الصباح
والبارحه مساء والبيانات التي صدرت ايضا
عن وزاره الدفاع
تاكد على او تجدد الدعوه في كل
وقف اطلاق النار وهذا المره في اخر بيان
من الاوساط الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه التي
ترغب ان يرسلها دور ما على هذا المستوى
وهذا هو ما فهم ايضا للحديث الرئيس
الفرنسي
المجلس الامن
شكرا لك محمد تسهيل هما عمليه
شكرا محمد البقالي مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا
من باريس